So we tell you that persona is really important in designing applications. So
let's now talk about the mobile persona. Now, when you think about your
applications persona, no matter how different they are. No matter what they are
exactly they have to inherit from this
superclass which is the mobile user persona.
>> So that means that you need to take the attributes of the mobile user persona
into account as well as the attributes of
your apps persona. So Izabel, what are the attributes
of this mobile user persona?
>> Well, the first attribute would be that they have
a finite data plan and finite amount of battery they also
have divided attention. Yeah, exactly when I'm using my phone I'm
always doing like five or six things at the same time.
>> There's also something called handedness, which has to do
with how the user holds the phone in their hands.
>> And then, of course the mobile user has a very small screen.
>> And also, because the user's moving
around, they usually have very sketchy network
access. Yeah. This is a really important one and we
will dive into this much more deeply in lesson four.
>> I think it's really interesting that with these
mobile persona attributes that some of them are actually
a result of the form factor of the phone,
like having a small screen. Yeah. Yeah, others are
actually a result of human form factors our hands
only move in certain ways. Our brains actually work
in certain ways which is why we have divided
attention when were moving around doing six things at once.
>> And also some of them have to do with what it
means to be mobile like when your interacting within a physical environment.
>> You have things like your network can be sketchy because if you go
inside of a building or inside of
an elevator and things like that. Yeah, exactly.
>> So, I think that these attributes are
so important and they're so concrete that they're-
>> we think of them more as constraints
and not just attributes, meaning you can't violate
them at all or your users is going to have a really bad time. Yeah that's
true and don't think that because we're using the word
"constraint" that you're limited in some way. Innovation is spurred
as a result of constraints. So it's our challenge to
actually leverage these constraints and
create really compelling experiences given that
this users going to have finite data and battery divided attention
and all those other limitations. And we should also, since
we're in the subject of constraints let's not forget about
the power that you have on mobile. You can create amazing
real-time location based experiences that are
simply not possible on web and desktop.